YUFENG GUO: Welcome
to "AI Adventures,"
where we explore
the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we'll train a scikit-learn
model and deploy it
on Google Cloud ML Engine.
Take this information and use
it to set up your own deployment
pipeline and you'll
never need to worry
about how to deploy and
scale your models again.
Say you have some
data, you've trained up
on a scikit-learn
model, and now you
want to set up a
prediction server.
Let's see how you'd do
that based on the code
that we had in a previous
episode about zoo animals.
First, we got to
export the model,
so we'll use the joblib
library from sklearn.externals.
We can use joblib.dump to
export the model to a file.
Once we commit and
run this, we'll
be able to retrieve the
output from our Kaggle kernel.
And here we are
ready for download.
With our trained
scikit-learn model in hand,
we are ready to head over to
Google Cloud Machine Learning
Engine and load up the
model to serve predictions.
That's right, you can get
all the auto scaling secured
REST API goodness not only
for TensorFlow, but also
for scikit-learn.
Cloud ML Engine has
traditionally worked only
for TensorFlow, but now it also
supports scikit-learn as well
as XGBoost.
This enables you to easily
transition back and forth
between scikit-learn and
TensorFlow and XGBoost
without having to rework your
plumbing or architecture.
The first step to getting
our model in the cloud
is to upload the joblib file
to Google Cloud Storage.
It is required that
the name of the file
be literally model.joblib.
So be sure to stick
it inside a folder
with a name you'll
remember, otherwise you'll
end up with more models later
and they'll all be the name.
So we'll use that folder name
to locate the model later.
Now let's create our
model and version,
and we got to make sure we
specify that we're loading up
a scikit-learn model and select
the runtime version of Cloud ML
Engine as well as
the version of Python
that we used to
export this model.
Since we were running on
Kaggle, that's Python 3.
And well, that's really
all there is to it.
We now have a scikit-learn
model serving in the cloud.
Now, of course, a scalable
model is no use to anyone
without being able to
call those predictions.
So let's take a simple
look at how that is done.
I've gone ahead and
pulled one sample row
from our data whose answer
should be category 4.
Now, what we can do
is present that data
to Cloud ML Engine as just a
simple array encoded as a JSON
file.
Here I'm taking the test
features data frame,
and then we'll extract
row 10 from it,
and then we'll call .values to
get the underlying numpy array.
Unfortunately,
numpy arrays don't
print with commas
between their values.
So we really want the commas.
So we then wrapped it and turned
the numpy array into a Python
list to be printed out.
So we have our list, we have
it saved to an input file,
and now we can call
the prediction REST API
for our scikit-learn model.
G Cloud has a built in
utility to do that for us,
and we're expecting a response
of 4, and yes, we got it.
You can follow these
steps in this video
to deploy your scikit-learn
model to production,
or even step it up by turning
it into an entire automated
pipeline so that, every
time you make a new model,
it can get deployed
out so you can test it.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed it,
please hit the Like button
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, head on over
to Cloud ML Engine
and upload your
scikit-learn model
to get auto scaling predictions
right at your fingertips.